[Musique]
je viens de vous dire que les décisions
avaient été prises ce pas là la
situation de réanimation en maintenant
deux semaines pourrait être celle que
nous avons connue au pic de la première
vague
donc cela nécessite une nouvelle étape
se ramasser ce soir un président de la
république pour le reste je n'ai
vraiment pas rentrer dans les
qualifications de mesures qui pourraient
être annoncées sur la page fan moi c'est
évident qu'il est vous annoncer aux
décisions qui coûteraient chaque fois
qu'il ya eu des décisions difficiles à
apprendre contraignante pour les
français nous avons toujours montré qu
évidemment en munitions aux français la
possibilité de s'adapter avec et la
bobine et une souplesse nécessaire ces
présages absolument rien ce qui pourra
commencer ce soir afin de nous dire tout
de suite at-elle une recommandation
avait été formulée et le canard enchaîné
qui décoiffe
fait qu' aucune blessure augmentations
ont été mises en oeuvre
je n'ai pas cet article je m'engage à
regarder à vous apporter une réponse
dans les plus brefs délais